arrête avec un thomas pause ados docteur
en sciences politiques et coauteur du
livre révolution à cuba de 1868 à nos
jours bonsoir et merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france pourquoi cette
réforme historique à cuba
aujourd'hui bonsoir alors si cette
réforme c'est pour essayer de lever ce
système de double monnaie double monique
comme vous l'expliquait existe depuis
1994 écrit un certain de distorsion
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de rassurer
des investisseurs potentiels dans le
cadre d'une crise économique qui est là
alors qui est grave dans la plupart des
pays de la planète mais ou à cuba
on a en son sein de récession cette
année et dans une économique est
particulièrement dépendante du tourisme
la crise sanitaire a un bac tu es encore
plus que les autres pays
l'économie cubaine on pensait avoir 5
millions de touristes cette année à cuba
au final il n'y en a eu qu'un million
environ
donc ça crée un fort manque à gagner
pour l'économie cubaine a ajouté à cela
un peu d'altran qui a durci ses
sanctions dans les derniers mois de son
mandat enfin les les boutiques western
union qui permettent aux ânes certain
nombre de cubains d'avoir des des
messages de l'argent envoyé par des
proches qui sont à l'étranger ont fermé
sur le territoire cubain six dernières
semaines et ça crée une situation
d'autant plus difficiles pour les
cubains
le pays est déjà affecté par l'embargo
américain la pandémie vous l'avez
rappelé la crise économique
internationale le président du plr connu
même elle vous semble intervenir malgré
tout au bon moment cette réforme
hors jeu l'asse au bon moment s'il me
les formes qui constitue un enjeu majeur
vous le rappeliez dans les images
introductive et qu'il ya un risque
d'inflation qui est extrêmement fort et
qu'il ya un risque de creusement des
inégalités qui est extrêmement fort
l'enjeu majeur est la raison pour
laquelle fut lui le gouvernement fait
cette réforme si bruce yebda
dames d'accueillir des investisseurs et
de faire appel à des investisseurs dans
une période où le commerce international
comme on voit partout dans le monde
connaît de très grandes difficultés
et oui c'est difficile de faire venir
des capitaux maintenant ces réformes
elle va avoir des conséquences très
cruel pour les cubains et en particulier
pour les cubains qui sont le plus dans
le besoin c'est cette réforme la liste
de creuser les inégalités qui sont déjà
on voit d'accroissement déjà à cuba donc
si on vous comprend bien cette réforme
vise en priorité les investisseurs
étrangers de nombreux cubains craignent
aujourd'hui de voir leur épargne au plus
bas est ce qu'il est en risque
effectivement il est réel et l'irréel
parce que on ne connaît pas cette
réforme elle entérine une dévaluation de
fait de la monnaie cubaine une
dévaluation extrêmement importante on va
être visé par 24 cette valeur à
s'aligner sur le cul sur le peso
convertible qui est donc aligné sur le
dollar
et c'est l'enjeu c'est pour ça que vous
mentionnez dans vos images introductive
le les salaires et les pensions vont
être augmentés de 452 500 % parce que
les prix risquent d'augmenter d'autant
mêmes voire plus
quelques produits vont être préservés le
lait infantile quelques produits
pharmaceutiques mais des craintes sont
sont majeurs aujourd'hui dans la société
cubaine sur les effets de cette réforme
le gouvernement promet de contrôler les
prix il a une expérience d'organisation
et de contrôle des prix de contrôle de
l'économie
mais on n'est pas à l'abri d'un
processus économique qui soit qu'ils
soient incontrôlée ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que ce processus de
restauration d'une économie de marché il
existe à cuba depuis de nombreuses
années mais de manière lente et
tortueuse contre hamas qui a pu se faire
de manière extrêmement rapide en chine
et au vietnam tuba par la pression à des
états unis
on essaye de restaurer mais tous avec
une direction gouvernementale qui essaye
de garder le contrôle de cette
restauration de l'économie de marché
parce qu'elle a elle peut avoir des
conséquences imprévisibles et un
équilibre politique qui pourrait devenir
extrêmement fragile avec une communauté
cubaine à miami qui n'attendent qu'une
faiblesse du gouvernement cubain pour
pour pourvoir son renversement
quant aux derniers mots assez rapidement
si vous le voulez bien parce que le
temps me manque
concernant les états unis justement le
président cubain a évoqué la volonté je
cite de construire une relation
respectueuse et durable entre les deux
nations
quelles perspectives pour les prochains
échanges entre les américains et les
cubains en deux mots s'il vous plaît
alors on peut espérer qu si cela
s'améliore obama avait inauguré une
restauration des échanges maintenant la
nomination d' anthony blinken qui est
donc le nouveau secrétaire d'état de joe
biden bas laissent présager d'une
politique plutôt interventionniste et
donc est ce que les mener au principe de
donald trump vont être supprimés d'un
coup plume c'est toute la question est
ce qu'un petit d'une 15 sera l'homme qui
revient à prendre d'obama ou est-ce
qu'il maintiendra le durcissement des
sanctions de 2000 points
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
tan ap aux ados docteur en sciences
politiques je rappelle le titre de votre
ouvrage révolution à cuba de 1868 à nos
jours